بعد 33 عامًا من العمل كرجل إطفاء ،
تقاعد تشاك ستينغر بالطريقة التي كان
يريدها ، كان علي أن أعطي
كل شيء تقريبًا ، نقلتني إدارة الإطفاء
إلى الوقاية
والتحقيقات على مدار السنوات الخمس الأخيرة
من مسيرتي المهنية بسبب هذا
أصيبت ركبته بجروح متقطعة  لسنوات ولكن قبل
تقاعده في مكالمة هاتفية ، أحبطه الألم
، شعرت أنه تم دفع سكين
في ركبتي ، تم
تشخيص ستينغر بهشاشة العظام ، لكنني
قلق بشأن وقت التعافي والحصيلة التي
قد يستغرقها استبدال الركبة بالكامل عندما
وجدت هذا  دراسة قلت إنني
سأشترك فيها ، حيث
تضمنت التجربة السريرية للمركز الطبي المتعدد جهازًا
مزروعًا في ركبة المريض ، ونحن
نبحث في ممتص صدمات مشابه
لما قد تراه في سيارة دكتور ديفيد
فلاناغان في ويكسنر بولاية أوهايو
يقول المركز الطبي إن 90 في المائة من المرضى
الذين حصلوا على الجهاز في
مستشفاه قد شهدوا تحسنًا في الأداء الوظيفي
وألمًا أقل ، حيث يتعرضون لصدمة كبيرة أو
بعض هذه القوة التي تسبب الإجهاد  أن
الركبة ترى عندما تحمل الوزن
ويمكن أن يكون ذلك أكثر من 30 في المائة من تلك
الصدمة أو ذلك الضغط حيث يتم
تفريغ ذلك من تلك المقصورة
التي تتضمن Stinger الذي كان يمتلك
الجهاز الآن لمدة ثلاث سنوات ، مما جعل
حياتي كاملة مرة أخرى.
أنا قادر على تسلق السلالم ، لقد عدت
للعب الجولف مرة أخرى ليس جيدًا ولكني ما زلت ألعب
الجولف من أجل الصحة لحظة أنا آندي
غايثر